(rock music)
(sighs)
- Can you hold that?
Can you hold that for me please?
Oh, I am so sorry.
Sorry.
- No, no, no, it's okay.
- You're Josh Duhamel.
- Mhmm.
- I was rushing,
actually, to get to you.
- Ah, oh you're here for the--
- Yeah I am.
This is my first--
- This is your first junket?
- Very first one.
- Well nice to
meet you, I'm Josh.
- Brian.
- Yeah there's no need to rush.
They can't start without me.
(laughing)
I hate these things.
They ask the same goddamn
questions every day
and it's like...
- And I got a whole lot of
great questions prepared.
- Good.
Yeah I just come in
here to clear my head.
You know, little peace and quiet
before the storm,
you know what I mean?
I'm not masturbating or
anything, just so you know.
- Okay.
- That would be creepy.
- Okay, yeah.
Didn't cross my mind once, so.
- I'm not a creep.
- I understand.
- Okay, good.
- Yep.
It was great to meet you.
- Welcome to the jungle, man.
- Thanks so much.
- All right.
(pants unzipping)
(snoring)
- Fuck you Oprah!
- Whoa.
You all right man?
- I thought I was back
at the Butler junket.
Am I, is Josh ready for me?
- You're Kevin Donnelly!
Oh my god this is so cool.
I used to watch
you all the time.
Brian Butler, Downloader.
- Hey Brian, thanks
for your support there.
Oh the Downloader.com,
that's adorable.
Is that like a podcast you
do in your mom's basement?
- No, no it's not.
- Let me guess, you
went to film school?
- Yeah.
- You got a few favorite movies?
- Of course.
- The Godfather.
- Yeah.
- Casablanca.
- Yes!
(chuckles)
- There are hot dogs over here.
- Good talk.
- Josh, good to see you.
This movie's cute.
- Thank you.
- Looks really great.
In the production notes,
the summary was very cute.
- Oh so you haven't actually--
- I'm gonna see it probably.
How are you, good to see you.
I'm having a fucking
hell of a day.
- Are you doing okay?
- Well that's just it.
You know Britney.
- I know Britney, yeah I
see you two all the time.
- She's leaving me.
She's leaving me, yeah.
There was a little incident
with my chambermaid
when I was in a hotel.
- Oh yeah.
- I got a blowjob
from the chambermaid.
Britney picks up on it.
She's upset, and then
she springs with me
that she's boning our gardener.
- No way!
What a mess.
- And I was giving
this moron a leg up
and he's boning my wife.
- I'm sorry I asked.
- She's a dingbat, but
loves it in the caboose.
- Loves what?
- Loves it in the caboose.
- Love sick in the--
- Loves it.
- Loves it in the caboose.
I thought you said
she was lovesick--
- She's a dingbat,
but loves it in...
- [Voiceover] One minute.
- Protein shake.
(chuckles)
- I think that's it.
I think we're done.
- This movie looks terrific.
- It was good to see you man.
I wish you all the best.
- Do we have enough?
You think we got enough?
- I think we got it.
- Okay good.
- Christopher David.
- Brian Butler.
- Are you on Snapchat?
You should be on Snapchat.
- Oh my god I just ate
like 30 egg whites.
I feel like a fucking cow.
Are you talking about how you're
going to take Kevin's job?
- Maybe.
- Hi new guy.
- Hello.
- [Woman] Okay,
do a video of me.
- Yeah yeah, ready set go.
- Hi, Britney Fox here.
I'm just trying to stay hydrated
with my super alkaline
H3O fierce water.
- [Kevin] You know what,
nothing is more sexy
than to watch yous
shill for water.
- That is sexual
harassment okay?
And if I cared about that type
of thing I would report you.
Celebrity Wow fans are going
to love this movie so much.
- Thank you, we put a lot
of work into this one--
- But I gotta know,
how do you keep
your body in such great shape?
- I guess I work
out a little bit.
- I mean can I just like?
- No, actually, please.
- I mean look at
these, it's just so.
That's crazy, just
let it happen.
I won't stop 'til
I get what I want.
- Okay, there you go.
- You know I'm getting
a divorce, right?
- You sound so
excited about that.
- I'm actually in a
really dark place,
but you know gotta
keep it professional.
- Hold down the
button, you get lots
and lots of views,
if I'm in them.
- Shoot yourself now.
- Oh he's so old and gross.
He may as well die right now.
I'd be happy.
- Hey Christopher David
here with The Buzz
and I'm with my main
man, Josh Duhamel,
how you doing buddy?
- Duhamel.
- Spaceman man,
performance of a lifetime.
- Oh.
- Wait, do you hear that?
Oh my god just a second.
This is big news coming through.
That's the buzz buzz buzz of
Oscar calling for you, buddy,
and you heard it here
first on The Buzz.
(laughs)
- Jesus Christ are you serious?
- I have never done
one of these before.
- They're so supes easy.
All you do is you walk in the
room, you get eight minutes.
- No they get eight
minutes, 'cause
they're national and it's
the whole patriarchy.
Guys like you and me, we get
four, 'cause we're online.
Decker, movieleaks.com.
- I know you, you ran that
rumor about Chris Pratt
playing a young Yoda in
the Star Wars spinoff?
- Okay I trusted a source.
Josh, Josh, Josh.
- So you're going
to stay on topic?
- I always do.
Okay so in Transformers
Dark of the Moon
Optimus Prime revives
Sentinel Prime
with his matrix of
leadership, but--
- You saw Spaceman right?
The movie that we're
here to talk about?
- Yeah, yeah I was super excited
to see a movie called Spaceman.
But then found out it
was about baseball.
Do you feel like that
might be misleading?
- No I don't feel like
that's misleading.
His name was Bill Spaceman.
- Sports are, sports are fun.
So the entire
cyber tron planet--
- No more talking
Dark of the Moon.
- Okay, okay.
So in Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen--
- He's such a dick.
- You guys got any
last advice for me?
(snoring)
Wish me luck.
- Name and affiliation.
- Brian Butler
thedownloader.com.
So--
- So you're going to
stay on topic, right?
Your other cohorts have
been all over the place.
- Got it, cool.
So I watched the
movie, it's great,
and I noticed that this
guy you play really
represents that classic
antihero archetype.
- You really watched
the movie didn't you?
- Honestly I loved it.
- I think you're the only guy in
this whole junket who
watched the movie.
- Can't be, it was so good.
- Thank you.
- Well?
- He said it was his favorite
interview of the day.
- All right, welcome to the biz!
Pew pew pew pew pew!
- Sorry.
Sorry.
- This is all I got, Brian.
I'm not the only
one that does this!